Glass, to me, is crazy cool.
I make a collection of very
bespoke and unique glass objects
that have their own aesthetic.
I went to high school in Bermuda, and from an early age,
I was lucky enough to have a kiln.
What fascinates me most, is how you can create
something organically
with limited resources.
All you need is mud
and a flame to ignite it,
then voilà, you've got a sculpture
that will last forever.
In the past, I've looked at woodwork,
metalwork and digital processes,
but eventually, I chose glass as my main medium.
When I discovered glass-blowing
and glass-sculpting,
I was immediately fascinated
with how a material could be manipulated
in so many different ways.
Mold-blowing
is one of the oldest techniques.
In my own practice
I make dozens of pieces
from one digital mold,
which is really sustainable,
as there are no by-products or waste.
My work begins with sketches
and drawings,
which then evolve
onto a digital platform,
to carry out a computerised edit.
From that point,
I moved on to 3D-sculpting
and 3D-cutting
to form objects from the sketches.
When I started working
in a more professional capacity,
I became aware
of the limitations of glass-making
and how inaccessible it was
in certain places around the world.
The cultural imprint
behind glass-making,
exists even today.
I'm want to inspire
young people
from all backgrounds and ethnicities.
It's really important
for people to be aware
that if an occupation
doesn't seem viable to them,
because of the colour of their skin
or their personality,
they shouldn't give up.
If you have a passion for something,
you should pursue it.
Sometimes you have
to change the status quo.
When I'm working with glass,
there's a constant battle
between how I think and how I feel.
There's a sense of suspense and drama,
because if you don't concentrate
on what you're doing,
it could all go terribly wrong.
It's a constant battle with weight, sweat, heat and fire.
One of the roles that traditional
methods play in my own work
is continuity.
In my work
there's a real sense of history,
and I think it's important to acknowledge
the culture and heritage of glass-making.
It's great to be able to amalgamate
digital-based concepts and designs
with more traditional methods
to create an original, contemporary style.